hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be one of my first doctor who series 9
videos I've already done a trailer
breakdown but I always get a lot of
requests for like wait you know where to
start watching so this is going to be a
video for where to start if you've never
watched Doctor Who before we're getting
ready to enter series 9 but this is the
second year for the new doctor Peter
Capaldi if you're not familiar with him
and you're not familiar with the doctors
the way the show keeps going for so long
it's been going since the 1960s is it's
that every couple of years the doctor
regenerates and they reboot the show
when fans talk about Doctor Who
typically they talk about two different
eras there's classic who which is like
everything from the 1960s up to a TV
movie in the 1990s and then there's new
who which didn't start till 2005 that
the show was off the air for a number of
years and then Russell T Davies brought
it back with the BBC but even though
they did like a ground-up reimagining of
the show they still reference a lot of
stuff from classic who you know a lot of
people make fun of the way showrunners
deal with continuity going back to
classic who in the 1960s but for the
most part likelike look at this picture
of peter capaldi on set right now I mean
this is out of context but he's wearing
this red crushed velvet jacket that
looks mysteriously like the Third
Doctor's jacket so the writers find
creative ways of bringing back things
from classic who from from way way back
and using them in news stories there is
a very famous rogue's gallery of
villains that we tend to see on a
recurring basis the the Daleks are
probably the most famous next to the
master who is now actually a woman the
master and the doctor exists in this
Sherlock Moriarty relationship where
about you know the master used to be the
doctor's greatest childhood friend it is
now one of his greatest enemies so some
of my episode recommendations will be
for specific concepts like regeneration
and some will be for specific characters
like like the master or the Daleks
people always wonder do I have to watch
all of classic who to understand what's
going on in in New who like could you
like walk in blind to series 9 yes you
could but it helps to watch like one or
two episodes for certain characters if
we know that they're coming the BBC
always wants like new people to start
watching Doctor Who so they don't they
try not to like punish you for not
having watched all of Doctor Who even if
you've never watched Doctor Who before
you probably seen the blue box the
TARDIS before you
may not know what it's called but it's
actually the one that I have right here
this little toy it's what you would call
the doctor's spaceship it's it's how he
travels through time and space it's
actually a living being it's like a
living machine doctor who is a show is
something of science fantasy like like
in the way Star Wars is science fantasy
last year's season was Peter Capaldi's
first so you know I think that they
wanted to go a little more hardcore so
they did a few more scary episodes and
Steven Moffat the showrunner always
likes to joke about terrifying new
generations of children so they have
been having some you know fun with the
idea of this doctors being like a really
terrifying schoolmaster as opposed to
the heartthrob that Matt Smith was if
you miss Matt Smith's run he was the
person to play the doctor before Peter
Capaldi who would you know which is like
the opposite of the spectrum he was the
youngest person to ever play the
character and speaking of young the
Companions if you're not familiar with
Doctor Who companions that the doctor
picks a person to travel with him
sometimes for fun sometimes out of
necessity sometimes like there's this
destiny aspect that they try to weave
into it the twist is that as much as the
show is the this really fun side fantasy
adventure the Companions usually meet
fairly untimely faiths it usually ends
in tragedy like you get your childhoods
wish to see all of time and space but
you pay the price for that sometimes the
doctor ends up leaving you in the future
that's actually would happen to his
granddaughter Susan everyone's talking
about her because they want Maisie
Williams from that from the series night
trailer to be her he might strain you in
the future you might be rendered
immortal forced to die and be
resurrected over and over and over like
Captain Jack you might even be turned
into a goddess I think you know probably
one of the most sad companion endings
would be for Donna Noble she was one of
David tenets companions he was the
doctor before Matt Smith she almost
suffered the exact same fate as rose and
got turned into like this dr. hybrid so
the doctor had to wipe her mind so that
the sheer force of what was happening to
her wouldn't destroyed her so it's
almost like for her she never got to
experience anything like the amazing
adventures with the doctor which which i
think is just like the saddest thing
ever but at any given time each
companion influences the tone of the
show like you a really good fan of buddy
cop flicks Donna in the David Tennant
doctor that was basically like a buddy
cop relationship the current companion
Clara with Peter
capaldi the current doctor is more of
like a grumpy old wizard with an
apprentice which is actually funny
because the first series 9 episode is
called The Magician's apprentice so if
your big Merlin fan just expect Doctor
Who to play with that idea just a little
bit I mean the show itself isn't about
magic but they do have fun with fantasy
concepts but really like the biggest
concepts that you need to understand are
like Who the master is who the Time
Lords are the race that the doctor
belongs to who Clara is how regeneration
works and how the TARDIS works so if
you're going to start somewhere I would
start with David Tennant's the end of
time yeah a lot of you a point to this
as being the finale so it's kind of a
weird choice but it does a really good
job of telling the story of the master
and the doctors a child in their
relationship with the Time Lords the
doctor is a very nice person but the
Time Lords are very bad after you watch
the end of time watch series 5 episode 1
that was the very first Matt Smith
episode after the end of time then
watched the 50th anniversary it invokes
a lot of classic who and the time wore
this really big event in Time Lord
history plus it's basically like like a
really well done movie they they
actually they aired in the theaters it's
one of the best episodes of Doctor Who
of all time then watch series 6 episode
13 that's the christmas special the
snowmen that was Cara's very first
episode they introduced the idea of the
impossible girl like multiple Clara's
that all keep dying across time and
space then watch series 7 episode 10
that's journey to the center of the
TARDIS that gets Beckett's into like how
the TARDIS works why it's alive they
actually explained the engine that
drives the TARDIS and in how it is that
it changes shape then you can watch
series 8 which was the season last
season Peter Capaldi's first run episode
1 of series 9 premieres saturday
September 19th so if you feel like you
have enough time then just watch
everything from the 2005 reboot
everything from series 12 now that's
like that's a lot of TV but it's on
netflix so the runs are short in just a
little bit so you might be able to get
it all in that's like the hardcore route
though but if you don't have time for
that actually I'm going to add one to
like my bare minimum list it's called
the fires of Pompeii it's going to be
really important to a storyline in
series 9 and it stars Peter Capaldi
in a role that he had before he became
the doctor the show has been going on
for a long long time so sometimes actors
will come on as guest stars and really
minor roles and then they'll come back
on the show in a bigger role the same
thing happened to the person that was
the sixth doctor now Peter Capaldi just
just for reference as the 12th person to
play the doctor so even though it's
series 9 he is the 12th doctor it can
get kind of confusing because they like
they rewrite continuity during the 50th
anniversary special there was a person
called the war doctor so people like to
argue about you know whether there's 12
or 13 doctors you know for all intents
and purposes there's 12 but don't worry
about that too much Colin Baker who was
the sixth doctor actually start on
Doctor Who in a guest role before he
became the doctor so he did the same
thing that Peter Capaldi the current
doctor did Steven Moffat has said that
there will be an episode this year that
will explain why Peter Capaldi has the
same face as this character here from
series for that episode also stars Karen
Gillan who went on to like come back on
the show in a different role as a
companion so doctor who can be like
really confusing sometimes if you
haven't been watching it for a little
while but that's why I like whenever I
do videos for episodes like I try to
reference specific stuff like this so I
try to make it as easy to watch as
possible if you guys have any requests
for bonus videos explaining certain
concepts or are certain villains just
let me know in the comments below I've
already done a couple explaining like my
favorite master episodes and i did a
video last year explaining a couple
episodes to watch so i'll put links in
the description for a couple good bonus
videos to check out next it's going to
be a really fun season in the good thing
about Doctor Who is that it airs on a
Saturday so there's like there's no
competition with like other shows like I
know it's really hard to watch more than
one or two shows in any night so here's
my question for you guys like when
you're talking to your friend that
doesn't know anything about Doctor Who
which episode do you tell them to start
with what is like the very first episode
you think someone new to doctor who
should check out I always laugh a little
bit when people ask you know like what's
the most important episode of Doctor Who
how much do I have to watch and people
say you have to watch it all like all 50
plus years but that's why I try to do
like these general explainer videos for
like really important concepts and in
you know if you do want to go deep if
you want to go hard
corn to Doctor Who it's all there most
of it's on netflix right now but what's
probably happen which the season starts
is that I'll do like a friday night
bonus video and then i'll do saturday
episode videos i don't know if i'll be
i'll be doing q and a's this year just
because sunday i'll be doing walking
dead videos because walking dead and
doctor who'll be on at the same time so
so they'll be like a certain conflict
and i usually do Game of Thrones videos
on Sundays too so don't worry I'll
figure it out like once we get closer to
the season I'll post like my official
video schedule for each week and because
we are getting ready for the season I'm
going to start my weekly doctor who give
away I'm just going to go ahead and
start it right now so all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video they'll just be
like a new doctor who give away each
time I post a new Doctor Who bonus video
and that will continue through series 9
like all the series 9 episodes there's
12 of those in a Christmas special also
don't forget I know a lot of you been
asking me to do a Sherlock video from
comic-con I just I haven't quite had
time to do it yet there is a Sherlock
Christmas special that's a full 90
minutes long so get really excited about
that but it's like it's not in the
current continuity of Sherlock right now
it's set in the past it's kind of a
weird concept so I'll do video
explaining that so while you guys wait
for all that stuff to post you can click
here for the the video that I did last
year kind of explaining where to start
with Doctor Who I just have like a
couple different recommendations I
usually try to adjust every year and you
can click here for my breakdown of the
series 9 trailer thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you